[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it is this week the year
anniversary the beginning of the robert
muller russia investigation and at the
end of that period we have discovered
there is still no evidence at all of
collusion between the Donald Trump for
president campaign of 2016 and the
Russian government but Muller's many
supporters in Washington don't seem to
care about that that's because the
investigation was never about Russia
obviously the whole absurd fevered dream
was always a way for the ruling class to
feel better about losing power in 2016
it was a waited for them to avoid
thinking about why Trump got elected and
they never have thought about it along
the way the investigation has provided
Democrats with a full year of
government-funded Oppo research and
destroyed the lives of a number of
people who supported Donald Trump those
are added bonuses from the Democratic
perspective but there have been
downsides for Democrats voters are not
impressed by the Russia story it is
weird and false and confusing it is
precisely nothing to do with voters
actual lives or the issues they vote on
it's a total waste of time for everyone
and yet it's all Democrats have Trump is
evil so is Russia that's the entire
progressive program 2018 summarized in
two sentences if the Democratic Party
had a Sermon on the Mount those would be
the Beatitudes no wonder their approval
numbers are falling Republican
congressman Todd Rosita of Indiana has
introduced a resolution calling for an
end to Miller's investigation or a
report within 30 days he joins us along
with fellow Republican Ron de Santos of
Florida he says he may know the identity
of the person who spied on Trump's
campaign for the FBI in 2016
gentlemen welcome to you both tonight
congressman ochio first to you so this
resolution would call for an end to the
investigation or a report summarizing
its findings so far i misstating that no
votes correct Tucker the fact of the
matter is it's been a year as you say
it's been twenty million dollars and we
need to see a report of what evidence he
has and absent that evidence it should
wind up within 30 days of the resolution
passing so why wouldn't other members on
both sides in the Congress want some
oversight I mean it's your Constitution
we bound to provide oversight of the DOJ
so why are you the only person calling
for this well I'm not Matt Gaetz is also
calling for it there's a couple others
calling for it but we need your view or
yeah call your members of Congress and
get them on board you can only have a
free Republic as you know Tucker if you
have transparency and this is exactly
what we need
it is a witch-hunt it's gone beyond an
investigation and the only evidence of
collusion that we found the only
evidence of criminality has been on the
Democrats so we're calling on Muller to
to show his hand or fold the deck even
if I believe the president colluded with
Vladimir Putin I'd be very concerned
about this investigation because the
parameters aren't clear the timeline is
opaque and it's not clear what the point
is so congressman DeSantis one of the
enduring mysteries of the past two weeks
has been the story of a mole or spy
within the Trump campaign feeding
information to the Russia investigation
have you any sense who that person might
be look I do Tucker but I think that the
issue needs to go through the proper
channels I'm not comfortable disclosing
who I think it is based on the evidence
that I have but I could say this the
American people deserve an answer up or
down did the FBI direct somebody to spy
on Donald Trump's campaign was somebody
actively working to undermine his
campaign and create the illusion of
collusion and if that's the case writing
that's more serious than the FISA abuse
I think it's more serious than
Rosenstein butchering this whole
appointing order with Muller from the
beginning so we need the answer to those
questions and they are not giving us the
answer right now Twitter they're
definitely not now I know you don't want
to risk libel by naming someone because
this has not been proved in court but
give us a sense of what you're talking
about are you saying that someone who
worked on the Trump campaign fed
information to law enforcement so if you
look at a Glenn Simpsons testimony from
fusion GPS he talked about there being a
human source and that was something that
was controversial time some people said
it was Papadopoulos it's not
Papadopoulos i thought he was referring
to so the issue is
he acknowledges there's a human source
Peter struck he opens up the
counterintelligence investigation in the
summer of 2016
what does he do the next day he goes to
Great Britain he goes to London and he's
meeting with people well how the heck
would you do that if you just opened the
investigation that day so I think in
that kind of the London Christopher
Steele Glen Simpson axis is probably the
individual that we're looking at but I
mean look that we need to know whether
this individual was spying or not I have
grave concerns about it but I think we
can get those questions answer when the
Justice Department ponies up the doc so
lastly you're absolutely right but last
follow-up on that is are you suggesting
or do you believe that this is someone
who was pressured into cooperating with
the investigation or someone who freely
sent information over about the campaign
oh I think it's the latter Tucker I
think that this would be somebody
potentially could have been paid by the
FBI you know like Steele was was there
was an agreement to pay Steele right so
that's we just need to answer that did
they pay anybody yes or no let's say
direct anyone to go the campaign yes or
no very easy questions to answer and
Tucker we needed I mean this is the
Obama f we are exactly you're exactly
I'm sorry congressman please go ahead
yeah Rhonda sentence is exactly right we
also need to know the relationship
between Muller and Comey
I mean Comey kicked this whole thing off
with with with a bogus FISA warrant and
and what is the relationship between
monarch home he did Muller give Comey
immunity does call me think he's above
the law
where are we going with all this that's
what needs to be investigated do you
bullet do you believe quickly
congressman do you believe that Jim
Comey has been offered immunity by the
Moller investigation oh I think it
stands to reason and I think we I think
the American people deserve to know that
would be shocking congressman thank you
both I appreciate that I hope you get to
the bottom of those we have all right
thanks thanks